Thank you. Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and ad-free, you can support Casefile on your preferred platform. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. On the morning of Saturday April 5 2008, married couple Tuomas and Katarina Lungton left their home in the Swedish city of Stockholm to begin a long journey northwest through the countryside. One hundred and ninety kilometres later they reached their destination, the small inland
谢谢。危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集最初发布在 Casefile 的 Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上，作为我们付费订阅者的早期福利。这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。为了提前且无广告地收听这些剧集，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持 Casefile。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。2008 年 4 月 5 日星期六早上，已婚夫妇图马斯和卡塔琳娜·朗顿离开他们位于瑞典斯德哥尔摩的家，开始了一段向西北穿越乡村的长途旅程。一百九十公里后，他们到达了目的地，那个内陆小
village of Skärerensund. The Lungtons were visiting their friends, the Tulbys, who lived nearby on the edge of Lake Gricken. Toulmas had brought his brand new digital camera with him and he spent the day testing it out by documenting the group's activities. After a barbecue lunch, they took a stroll into town. activities. After a barbecue lunch, they took a stroll into town. As they wandered down the rural forested roads towards Sherensund, Tormas snapped candid photos of their journey, capturing the trees, birds and people they passed along the way. It was about 2.15pm when the group emerged from the forest and onto a main country road. There, Tumas spotted a young girl riding a white hybrid-style bicycle towards them.
村庄斯凯雷恩松德。朗顿夫妇正在拜访住在格里肯湖边附近的朋友图尔比一家。图马斯带上了他崭新的数码相机，并花了一整天时间通过记录团队的活动来测试它。烧烤午餐后，他们步行进城。当他们沿着乡村林间小路向斯凯雷恩松德漫步时，图马斯抓拍了他们旅途中的坦率照片，捕捉到了他们沿途经过的树木、鸟类和人们。大约下午 2 点 15 分，一行人从森林中走出来，来到一条乡村主干道上。在那里，图马斯发现一个年轻女孩正骑着一辆白色混合动力自行车朝他们驶来。
She was wearing black sports shoes, black tracksuit pants and an olive green winter coat zipped up to her chin. zipped up to her chin. Her long brown hair was pulled back by a headband and her brown eyes looked out from behind a pair of burgundy-rimmed glasses, focused on the road ahead. Eager to test out the sports feature of his new camera, Toulmas dashed across to the other side of the road and took a series of photos of the young cyclist as she pedalled past. the road and took a series of photos of the young cyclist as she pedalled past. When Tuomas rejoined his group, his friend Ulla Torbi asked, wasn't that Carina's daughter, Engla? Ulla's husband turned around just as the girl was preparing to turn right onto a gravel track that led into the forest. onto a gravel track that led into the forest.
她穿着黑色运动鞋、黑色运动裤，一件橄榄绿色的冬装外套拉链拉到了下巴。她棕色的长发用发带扎在脑后，棕色的眼睛从一副酒红色边框的眼镜后望出来，注视着前方的道路。为了测试新相机的运动功能，图马斯冲到马路对面，在年轻骑行者骑车经过时拍下了一系列照片。当图马斯回到他的团队时，他的朋友乌拉·托比问，那不是卡琳娜的女儿恩格拉吗？乌拉的丈夫转过身，正好看到那个女孩准备右转进入一条通往森林的碎石小路。
Sjörensund had barely 100 residents, making it easy to recognise 10-year-old Engla Herglund. It was clear she was heading home, as her family's cottage was nestled in the forest, just over 500 metres away. The End Earlier that day, Angela Herglund had ridden her bike into Scherensund to attend soccer practice. Before she left, she made a promise to her mother, Carina. Angela could ride home by herself as long as she called to check in with Karina along the way. Shortly before 2pm, Engler phoned her mother on a mobile phone to let her know that soccer practice had finished and she was heading home. The ride home was roughly 4km, which would take
斯凯雷恩松德只有不到 100 名居民，这使得人们很容易认出 10 岁的恩格拉·赫格伦。很明显她正要回家，因为她家的木屋就坐落在森林里，距离这里只有 500 多米。那天早些时候，安吉拉·赫格伦骑自行车去了斯凯雷恩松德参加足球训练。离开前，她向母亲卡琳娜做了一个承诺。安吉拉可以自己骑车回家，只要她在路上打电话向卡琳娜报平安。下午 2 点前不久，恩格拉用手机给母亲打电话，告诉她足球训练结束了，她正在回家路上。回家的路程大约 4 公里，这需要
Engler about 15 minutes to complete. At 2.09, Engler rang her mother again, dutifully reporting that her trip was going well and that she would be home very soon. As the minutes ticked by, Engler hadn't yet returned and Karina's phone remained silent. Engler's journey would have taken her down the main road and onto a 400 metre long gravel track through the forest From there, it was just 200 metres to the Herglands cottage Yet 2.30pm hit and Engla was nowhere to be seen Karina called her daughter's mobile to check what was holding her up There was no answer She tried several more times to no result
恩格拉大约 15 分钟才能完成。2 点 09 分，恩格拉再次给母亲打电话，尽职地报告说她的行程很顺利，很快就会到家。随着时间一分一秒过去，恩格拉还没有回来，卡琳娜的手机也一直保持沉默。恩格拉回家的路程本应是沿着主路，然后进入一条 400 米长的森林碎石小路。从那里到赫格伦家的小木屋只有 200 米。然而到了下午 2 点 30 分，恩格拉依然不见踪影。卡琳娜拨打女儿的手机想问问她被什么耽搁了。无人接听。她又试了几次，都没有结果。
Worried, Karina left home to walk the route Angler would have ridden from soccer practice She made it all the way into town, having found no sign of Angler along the way. It wasn't until Karina made her way back home that she made a significant discovery. As she approached the turn in the forest 200 metres from her family's cottage, Karina spotted a white bicycle abandoned a short distance away amongst the trees. It was Angler's. Carina immediately phoned the country police, who wasted no time in organising a search party to scour the forest for Angler, complete with tracking dogs and a helicopter. The small local community also rallied together to help search the expansive countryside. That evening, when local couple Peter and Ula Torby heard about
心急如焚的卡琳娜离开家，沿着恩格拉从足球训练回家的路线寻找。她一直走到镇上，沿途没有发现恩格拉的任何踪迹。直到卡琳娜回到家时，她才有了重大发现。当她接近距离自家木屋 200 米处的森林转弯处时，卡琳娜在不远处的树丛中发现了一辆被遗弃的白色自行车。那是恩格拉的。卡琳娜立即报警，警方迅速组织了搜救队，带着搜救犬和直升机在森林中搜寻恩格拉。当地的小社区也团结起来，帮助搜寻广阔的乡村。那天晚上，当当地夫妇彼得和乌拉·托比听说
Engla's disappearance, they realised they were the last people to have seen the 10-year-old before she rode into the forest and vanished. Their friend who was with them that afternoon, Tuomas Langton, looked back through the photos he had taken as the group walked into town. He had happened to capture Angla mid-ride right before she entered the forest. Less than a minute later, Tuomas had snapped another photo that captured a compact red vehicle driving along the road a short distance away. It was a late 90s Saab 9-3. Toulmas wasn't the only one who had noticed the red Saab. Local woman, Aunt Sophie Lexian, had been driving about two kilometres outside of town when she passed Angla
恩格拉失踪的消息时，他们意识到自己是恩格拉骑车进入森林并消失前最后见到她的人。那天下午和他们在一起的朋友图马斯·朗顿回顾了他步行进城时拍摄的照片。他碰巧在恩格拉进入森林前拍下了她骑车的样子。不到一分钟后，图马斯又拍下了一张照片，捕捉到一辆红色紧凑型汽车在不远处的路上行驶。那是一辆 90 年代末的萨博 9-3。图马斯并不是唯一注意到这辆红色萨博车的人。当地妇女索菲·莱克西安阿姨在开车经过离镇约两公里的地方时，超过了恩格拉
on her bike. Shortly after, Aunt Sophie spotted a man standing on the side of the road, leaning against a parked red Saab. He was facing oncoming traffic and smoking a cigarette. Aunt Sophie recognised the man, but she couldn't recall exactly who he was or why he looked familiar Driving onwards, Aunt Sophie then passed the Lungtons and Torbys on their walk into Sherensund Police showed Aunt Sophie the photographs taken by Thomas Lungton Sophie the photographs taken by Thomas Langton. She confirmed the red car travelling behind Engler was the same vehicle she'd seen the man leaning against. While she couldn't recognise him at the time, Aunt Sophie now realised she knew exactly who it was. He was a truck driver whom she'd met at the service station where she worked.
骑着的自行车。不久之后，索菲阿姨看到一个男人站在路边，靠在一辆停着的红色萨博车上。他面向迎面而来的车流，正在抽烟。索菲阿姨认出了那个男人，但她想不起他到底是谁，或者为什么看起来很眼熟。继续开车前行，索菲阿姨随后经过了步行前往斯凯雷恩松德的朗顿夫妇和托比夫妇。警方给索菲阿姨看了图马斯·朗顿拍摄的照片。她证实，在恩格拉身后行驶的那辆红色汽车正是她看到那个男人靠着的那辆。虽然当时她没认出他，但索菲阿姨现在意识到她完全知道那是谁。他是一名卡车司机，她在工作的加油站见过他。
His name was Anders Eklund. Records showed that Eklund owned a red Saab 9-3, but that wasn't all. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. 42-year-old Anders Eklund was born and raised in a small town 20 kilometres from Scherensund. For the most part, he led an unremarkable life. That was until the age of 30, when Eklund was convicted for the attempted rape of a young woman.
他的名字叫安德斯·埃克伦德。记录显示埃克伦德拥有一辆红色萨博 9-3，但这还不是全部。Case File 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供优质内容。42 岁的安德斯·埃克伦德在距离斯凯雷恩松德 20 公里外的一个小镇出生长大。在大多数情况下，他过着平庸的生活。直到 30 岁那年，埃克伦德因企图强奸一名年轻女子而被定罪。
He served 22 months in prison and upon his release, he assaulted a 16-year-old girl. Eklund was sent back to prison, but he was released again within six months. He then attempted to rape another 16-year-old girl as she slept in her bed. For this, he was convicted of sexual coercion and sentenced to four months prison. As reported by the publication Often Blooded, Eklund was evaluated as being low risk for repeat offences and was released back into the public. In 2000, he was fined for sexual harassment after exposing himself to a woman. Four years later, he was found in a girls' locker room. Engler Herglund had been missing for almost 30 hours by the time police finally caught up with Anders Eklund.
他入狱服刑 22 个月，出狱后又袭击了一名 16 岁女孩。埃克伦德被送回监狱，但在六个月内又被释放。随后，他又企图强奸另一名正在床上睡觉的 16 岁女孩。为此，他因性胁迫罪被定罪，并被判处四个月监禁。据《晚报》报道，埃克伦德被评估为再犯风险较低，并被释放回到社会。2000 年，他因向一名女性暴露身体而被罚款。四年后，他在一个女孩更衣室里被发现。恩格拉·赫格伦失踪近 30 小时后，警方终于找到了安德斯·埃克伦德。
His truck was spotted at a rest stop in southern Sweden, nearly 600 kilometres from Scherensund, not far from the border of Denmark. Police converged on the vehicle and found Eklund, who they promptly placed under arrest for suspicion of kidnapping. Engler was not with him. At the same time, police searched Eklund's studio apartment in his hometown. Beer bottles and clothing were strewn about the messy and cluttered space. Pornographic magazines were scattered across the floor and piled in a wardrobe. He was in possession of 17 films depicting illegal sex acts with animals and also had a collection of used women's underwear. But Engler Herglund was nowhere to be seen.
他的卡车在瑞典南部的一个休息站被发现，距离斯凯雷恩松德近 600 公里，离丹麦边境不远。警方包围了这辆车并发现了埃克伦德，随即以涉嫌绑架罪将他逮捕。恩格拉不在他身边。与此同时，警方搜查了埃克伦德在家乡的单身公寓。啤酒瓶和衣物散落在凌乱拥挤的空间里。色情杂志散落在地板上，堆在衣柜里。他持有 17 部描绘非法动物性行为的影片，还有一堆用过的女性内衣。但恩格拉·赫格伦不见踪影。
Analysis of Erklund's laptop revealed that he participated in online chat rooms that were accessible to users as young as 15. According to Uftenbladet, online, Erklund claimed to be a 37-year-old, quote, dark blonde, powerfully built truck driver. In reality, he was a bespectacled and overweight man with grey balding hair. 56 illicit images of children were also found saved to his hard drive. found saved to his hard drive. Carina Herglund woke on the third day of her daughter's disappearance to snow-covered ground. An arrest had been made, but the cold snap in the weather meant that if Angela was out in the elements, her chances of survival were low. Search efforts were consequently scaled down as police honed in
对埃克伦德笔记本电脑的分析显示，他参与了 15 岁以下用户也能进入的在线聊天室。据《晚报》报道，埃克伦德在网上自称是一名 37 岁、引用“深金发、身材魁梧的卡车司机”。实际上，他是一个戴着眼镜、超重、灰发秃顶的男人。在他的硬盘中还发现了 56 张非法儿童图片。卡琳娜·赫格伦在女儿失踪的第三天醒来时，地面已被积雪覆盖。虽然已经有人被捕，但寒冷的天气意味着如果恩格拉暴露在户外，她的生存几率很低。因此，搜救工作规模缩小，警方将重点放在
on Anders Eklund. Eklund denied having anything to do with Engla Herglund's disappearance and claimed to be shocked by the arrest. Police were able to obtain a sample of Eklund's DNA and, to their surprise, it led to an unexpected discovery. Eight years earlier in the summer of 2000, florist Pernilla Helgren packed her bags and left her home in Stockholm to begin a long journey through the Swedish countryside. The 31-year-old was headed to the inland town of Forlán to visit her mother for her 50th birthday. A party was held on the night of Saturday June 3, after which Pernilla and her sister left their mother's apartment and headed into town together. They visited two popular restaurants before getting swept up in the revelry of an annual street festival.
安德斯·埃克伦德身上。埃克伦德否认与恩格拉·赫格伦的失踪有任何关系，并声称对被捕感到震惊。警方设法获得了埃克伦德的 DNA 样本，令他们惊讶的是，这导致了一个意想不到的发现。八年前的 2000 年夏天，花商佩妮拉·赫尔格伦收拾行李离开斯德哥尔摩的家，开始了一段穿越瑞典乡村的长途旅程。这位 31 岁的女性正前往内陆城镇福兰，为她母亲庆祝 50 岁生日。6 月 3 日星期六晚上举行了派对，之后佩妮拉和她的妹妹离开母亲的公寓一起进城。她们参观了两家受欢迎的餐厅，随后被一年一度的街头节日的狂欢所吸引。
restaurants before getting swept up in the revelry of an annual street festival. It carried on into the early hours, and by 2am on Sunday June 4, Pernilla had had enough. Wanting to go to bed, she parted ways with her sister and walked off alone in the direction of her mother's apartment, which was a few kilometres away. Shortly after, teenager Linda Sherstrom was cycling home along a bike path about two kilometres south of Forlandstown Centre. As she approached a small bridge, she heard grunting and groaning coming from a nearby cluster of trees. Linda looked in the direction of the sound and saw a heavyset man sitting cross-legged on top of a slender woman. The woman's short blonde hair appeared to be stained with blood and it looked like the man had his hands wrapped around her throat.
餐厅，随后被一年一度的街头节日的狂欢所吸引。狂欢持续到凌晨，到 6 月 4 日星期日凌晨 2 点，佩妮拉已经玩够了。想去睡觉的她与妹妹分道扬镳，独自一人朝几公里外母亲的公寓走去。不久之后，十几岁的琳达·舍斯特伦正沿着福兰镇中心以南约两公里的自行车道骑车回家。当她接近一座小桥时，听到附近的一丛树木中传来哼哼声和呻吟声。琳达朝声音的方向看去，看到一个身材魁梧的男人正盘腿坐在一个苗条女人的身上。那个女人的短金发似乎沾满了血迹，看起来那个男人正用双手掐住她的喉咙。
Linda rushed home and immediately phoned one of her friends, whose father was a police officer. Authorities rushed to the overpass and discovered the body of Pernilla Helgrian. She had been sexually assaulted and strangled to death. The man responsible was nowhere to be seen. While Pernilla's killer had worn a condom, his DNA was recovered on the leg of her trousers. The sample was cross-checked against the DNA of 800 men, but there wasn't a match. In time, Pernilla's case went cold. That was until eight years later, when Anderses Eklund's DNA was filed following his arrest for the kidnapping of Engla Hergland. While Eklund's DNA didn't reveal anything about Engla's case, it came back as a match to Pernilla Helgren's killer.
琳达冲回家，立即给她的一个朋友打电话，那个朋友的父亲是一名警察。当局赶到立交桥，发现了佩妮拉·赫尔格伦的尸体。她遭到了性侵犯并被勒死。肇事者不见踪影。虽然佩妮拉的凶手戴了避孕套，但他的 DNA 在她裤子的腿部被提取出来。该样本与 800 名男性的 DNA 进行了交叉比对，但没有匹配。随着时间的推移，佩妮拉的案件成了悬案。直到八年后，安德斯·埃克伦德因绑架恩格拉·赫格伦被捕后，他的 DNA 被存档。虽然埃克伦德的 DNA 没有揭示关于恩格拉案件的任何信息，但它与佩妮拉·赫尔格伦的凶手匹配上了。
When detectives informed Eklund of this revelation, he requested a private conversation with his lawyer Afterwards, he told the detectives that what had happened that summer had been gnawing away at him for eight years Eklund had attended Forloon Street Festival on Sunday June 4 He was heading back to his car in the early hours when he spotted Pernilla Helgren walking down the road. They struck up a conversation, during which Eklund claimed Pernilla invited him back to her mother's house for sex. Eklund suggested they sleep into the nearby woods instead, but Penilla was apprehensive. Eklund dismissed her refusal and forced himself onto Penilla as they crossed a bridge spanning
当侦探将这一发现告知埃克伦德时，他要求与律师进行私人谈话。之后，他告诉侦探，那个夏天发生的事情已经折磨了他八年。埃克伦德参加了 6 月 4 日星期日的福兰街头节日。凌晨时分，他正准备回车里，这时他看到佩妮拉·赫尔格伦走在路上。他们攀谈起来，期间埃克伦德声称佩妮拉邀请他回她母亲家发生性关系。埃克伦德建议他们去附近的树林，但佩妮拉很担心。埃克伦德无视她的拒绝，在他们穿过一座横跨
a bike path. He struck her so hard in the head that she fell over the railing and rolled down the hill to the ground below. Blood seeped from her head wound. Eklund dragged Penilla into the nearby trees and proceeded to rape her. She tried to escape, but Eklund used his considerable weight to incapacitate her. Eklund claimed he never intended to kill Penilla, he just wanted to strangle her until she fell unconscious so it would give him the chance to flee. Investigators were unconvinced of Eklund's version of events. Whatever the truth, Eklund had confessed to raping and killing Pernilla Helgren. While the DNA had convinced investigators of this fact, they were still stunned that he openly admitted to it
自行车道的桥时强行对佩妮拉下手。他猛击她的头部，导致她翻过栏杆，滚下山坡摔在地上。血从她的头部伤口渗出。埃克伦德将佩妮拉拖进附近的树林，并开始强奸她。她试图逃跑，但埃克伦德利用他巨大的体重使她丧失了反抗能力。埃克伦德声称他从未打算杀死佩妮拉，他只是想勒住她直到她失去知觉，这样他就有机会逃跑。调查人员对埃克伦德的陈述并不信服。无论真相如何，埃克伦德已经承认强奸并杀害了佩妮拉·赫尔格伦。虽然 DNA 已经让调查人员确信了这一事实，但他们仍然对他公开承认这一点感到震惊。
Emboldened by Eklund's willingness to talk, interrogators once again brought up 10-year-old Engla Hergland Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Eklund maintained he had nothing to do with Engler's disappearance, but ultimately requested to speak to his lawyer in private again. Afterwards, he began to tell another story. On the afternoon of Saturday April 5 2008, Eklund claimed he'd been driving home when he pulled over just outside of Scherensund to smoke a cigarette.
受到埃克伦德配合意愿的鼓舞，审讯人员再次提到了 10 岁的恩格拉·赫格伦。Case File 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供优质内容。埃克伦德坚称他与恩格拉的失踪无关，但最终再次要求私下与律师交谈。之后，他开始讲述另一个故事。2008 年 4 月 5 日星期六下午，埃克伦德声称他正开车回家，在斯凯雷恩松德外停车抽烟。
Shortly after, Angela Herglund rode by on her bike. Eklund returned to his car and continued driving up the road. He noticed the right-hand turn onto the gravel track that led into the nearby woods. Eklund thought there might be some deforestation happening nearby and wondered if he could secure some work transporting woodchips in his truck. He turned onto the track and soon passed Engla again, who was cycling along the same route. A little further ahead, Eklund parked his car and got out. He wondered why Engler was cycling alone in such an isolated area. When she approached, Eklund asked if she lived nearby, to which Engler supposedly replied that she was taking a shortcut. Eklund claimed that Engler was acting arrogant and cheeky towards him and she kicked him in the leg.
不久之后，安吉拉·赫格伦骑着自行车经过。埃克伦德回到车里继续沿路行驶。他注意到了通往附近树林的碎石小路的右转弯。埃克伦德认为附近可能正在进行森林砍伐，想知道他是否能在他的卡车上找到一些运输木屑的工作。他转入小路，很快又经过了恩格拉，她正沿着同一条路线骑行。再往前一点，埃克伦德停下车走了出来。他想知道为什么恩格拉会在这样一个偏僻的地方独自骑车。当她靠近时，埃克伦德问她是否住在附近，恩格拉据称回答说她正在走捷径。埃克伦德声称恩格拉对他表现得傲慢无礼，还踢了他的腿。
This prompted Eklund to grab Engler and drag her towards him and she kicked him in the leg. This prompted Eklund to grab Engler and drag her towards his car. Although he denied it at first, Eklund eventually confessed to having sexually assaulted Engler. During the attack, Engler kicked Eklund again, causing him to stumble backwards. She tried to run away, but Eklund caught up with her quickly and threw her to the ground. He was so enraged that he suffered what he described as some kind of tunnel vision. This led him to put his full weight on Engler's chest while proceeding to strangle her with his bare hands. He then put Engler's
这促使埃克伦德抓住恩格拉并将她拖向他的车。虽然起初否认，但埃克伦德最终承认曾对恩格拉进行过性侵犯。在袭击过程中，恩格拉再次踢了埃克伦德，导致他向后踉跄。她试图逃跑，但埃克伦德很快追上她并将她摔倒在地。他非常愤怒，以至于出现了他所描述的某种“隧道视野”。这导致他将全身重量压在恩格拉的胸口，同时用双手勒住她。然后他把恩格拉的
lifeless body in the trunk of his car before throwing her bike amongst the surrounding trees. Eklund began driving away from the scene, but before long he heard a noise coming from the trunk. He stopped to investigate, realising it was the sound of Engla's mobile phone ringing in her jacket pocket. It was her mother checking to see why she hadn't come home yet. Eklund threw the phone off to the side of the road, then continued home. There he changed his clothes and made himself a coffee. He then got back into his car and continued driving, wanting to create as much distance between Engla and her home as possible.
毫无生气的尸体放进汽车后备箱，然后把她的自行车扔进周围的树丛中。埃克伦德开始开车离开现场，但没过多久，他听到后备箱里传来声音。他停下来查看，意识到那是恩格拉夹克口袋里手机响的声音。那是她母亲在查看她为什么还没回家。埃克伦德把手机扔到路边，然后继续回家。在那里，他换了衣服，给自己冲了一杯咖啡。然后他回到车里继续行驶，想尽可能拉开恩格拉与她家之间的距离。
Along the way, he stopped to buy cigarettes and eat a pizza until he reached a secluded forest. He removed Engla's body from the trunk of his car, doused her with petrol, and set her alight. On the drive home, Eklund visited a service station and washed his car. He found Engler's burgundy-rimmed glasses in the trunk and promptly threw them in a bin. His attempted clean-up wasn't perfect, as traces of Engler's blood were found on the tailgate of his car. Officers searched the forest where Eklund claimed to have left Engler's body,
沿途，他停下来买烟和吃披萨，直到到达一片偏僻的森林。他从后备箱里取出恩格拉的尸体，浇上汽油，并将她点燃。在回家的路上，埃克伦德去了一家加油站洗车。他在后备箱里发现了恩格拉的酒红色边框眼镜，并立即将其扔进垃圾桶。他的清理工作并不完美，因为在汽车的后挡板上发现了恩格拉的血迹。警官们搜查了埃克伦德声称留下恩格拉尸体的森林，
and soon found her charred remains. charred remains. Afterwards, a funeral service was held for Engler, with so many mourners packing out the church that many had to watch the event on large projector screens outside. The service was also broadcast live around the nation. This was a first for Sweden, a testament to the impact that Engler's ordeal had made It allowed the whole country to remember Engler as the spirited young girl she was, and not just a murder victim Under Sheckland faced trial for the rape and murders of Pernilla Helgrian and Engla Herglund in July 2008. With DNA and blood evidence linking him to both crime scenes, it was an open and shut case. Eklund took the stand and while he didn't deny the crimes, he blamed a side of himself that he
很快发现了她烧焦的遗骸。之后，恩格拉的葬礼举行了，教堂里挤满了哀悼者，许多人不得不在外面的大投影屏幕上观看仪式。仪式还在全国范围内进行了直播。这在瑞典是第一次，证明了恩格拉的遭遇所产生的影响。它让整个国家能够记住恩格拉是一个充满活力的年轻女孩，而不仅仅是一个谋杀受害者。2008 年 7 月，安德斯·埃克伦德因强奸和谋杀佩妮拉·赫尔格伦和恩格拉·赫格伦而受审。由于 DNA 和血液证据将他与两个犯罪现场联系起来，这是一个证据确凿的案件。埃克伦德出庭作证，虽然他没有否认罪行，但他将责任归咎于他内心的一个侧面，他
called Evil Lundesh. He admitted there was no logic in what he had done to Pernilla Helgrian, while still maintaining he had never intended to kill her. Eklund's lawyer attempted to mitigate his client's moral responsibility by likening Engla Herglund's fate to a tragic accident. He quoted the famous short story To Kill a Child by Stig Duggerman, a Swedish journalist who rose to prominence in the aftermath of World War II. In the piece, the protagonist accidentally kills a child by running over them with his car. Observers regarded this as an appalling attempt to elicit sympathy for Eklund
称之为“邪恶的埃克伦德”。他承认他对佩妮拉·赫尔格伦所做的事情毫无逻辑可言，同时仍然坚称他从未打算杀死她。埃克伦德的律师试图通过将恩格拉·赫格伦的命运比作一场悲剧性的意外来减轻他当事人的道德责任。他引用了瑞典记者斯蒂格·达格曼的著名短篇小说《杀死一个孩子》，这位记者在二战后声名鹊起。在作品中，主角因开车撞倒孩子而意外杀死了他。观察家们认为这是一种令人震惊的、试图为埃克伦德博取同情的行为。
It was particularly upsetting for Carina Hergland, who swore under her breath as the prose was read aloud Her profanities got louder and louder until she eventually shouted at Eklund and his lawyer, resulting in her removal from the courtroom. Before leaving, Karina looked directly at Eklund and snarled, Is that the best you can do? He stared back passively in response. Anders Eklund was found guilty on all counts and sentenced to life in prison The district court rejected the stories he concocted about the lead-up to both attacks In Pernilla's case, it was likely he had stalked her as she walked home alone from the street festival
这对卡琳娜·赫格伦来说尤其令人痛苦，当文章被大声朗读时，她低声咒骂。她的脏话越来越大声，直到她最终对埃克伦德和他的律师大喊大叫，导致她被带出法庭。离开前，卡琳娜直视埃克伦德并咆哮道：“这就是你能做的最好的吗？”他面无表情地回视。安德斯·埃克伦德被判所有罪名成立，并被判处终身监禁。地方法院驳回了他编造的关于两次袭击前因后果的故事。在佩妮拉的案件中，很可能是他在她独自从街头节日回家的路上跟踪了她。
She had not propositioned him like he had claimed She had not propositioned him like he had claimed. The court was also dismissive of Eklund's story about driving down the path that led him to Anglar in search of work. They had no doubts that his sole motivation to turn down the forested track was to assault the ten-year-old. Penilla's father spoke of how Eklund's guilty verdict brought to an end eight years of uncertainty. He described those times as a rollercoaster between hope and despair. Quote, Every time I woke up I knew there was someone on the loose that had murdered my daughter. on the loose that had murdered my daughter. Neither I nor my family have lived properly. Now it feels better, but far from good. You live with this every single day.
她并没有像他声称的那样向他提出性要求。法院也驳回了埃克伦德关于开车走那条小路是为了找工作才遇到恩格拉的故事。他们毫不怀疑他转入林间小路的唯一动机就是为了袭击这个十岁的女孩。佩妮拉的父亲谈到埃克伦德的有罪判决如何结束了八年的不确定性。他将那段时光描述为希望与绝望之间的过山车。引用：“每次我醒来，我就知道有一个杀害我女儿的人逍遥法外。我和我的家人都没有正常生活过。现在感觉好了一些，但远非美好。你每天都要带着这种痛苦生活。”
Ander Sheklund was housed in a sex offenders ward, where in 2014 he was attacked by his fellow inmates. As a result, the process began to have him moved to a new facility for his own safety. In 2018, after 10 years in prison, Eklund applied to have his life sentence commuted to a fixed term. This opened up the possibility of parole. His request was denied as the court found him to be a, quote, concrete and significant risk of relapsing into a serious crime. Eklund's request to move prisons was granted in 2020. Upon his arrival, Eklund was beaten by a fellow prisoner. Swedish authorities continue to investigate Anders Eklund as a possible suspect in other violent unsolved sex crimes across Sweden. In any case, he will die in prison. In any case, he will die in prison.
安德斯·埃克伦德被关押在性犯罪者病房，2014 年他在那里被同狱囚犯袭击。因此，为了他自己的安全，他被转移到新设施的程序开始了。2018 年，在服刑 10 年后，埃克伦德申请将他的终身监禁改为固定刑期。这开启了假释的可能性。他的请求被拒绝，因为法院认为他存在引用“再次犯下严重罪行的具体且重大的风险”。埃克伦德转移监狱的请求在 2020 年获得批准。抵达后，埃克伦德被一名囚犯殴打。瑞典当局继续调查安德斯·埃克伦德，将其作为瑞典各地其他未破暴力性犯罪的可能嫌疑人。无论如何，他将在监狱中度过余生。无论如何，他将在监狱中度过余生。
In the aftermath of Van der Scheklund's trial for the murders of Pernilla Helgren and Engla Hergland, information came to light that stunned the community. When police were first attempting to identify Pernilla's killer in the year 2000, they drew up a list of Sweden's known violent sex offenders. It featured 1,213 names. Anders Eklund was number 21. Linda Sjöström, the teenager who had witnessed Pernilla being throttled, provided what was described as first-class recollections of the man responsible. He was an overweight, thin-haired white man. This matched exactly with Andes Eklund's appearance. While the suspect list was gradually whittled down, Eklund's name remained.
在安德斯·埃克伦德因谋杀佩妮拉·赫尔格伦和恩格拉·赫格伦受审后，一些令社区震惊的信息浮出水面。当警方在 2000 年首次试图确定佩妮拉的凶手时，他们列出了一份瑞典已知的暴力性犯罪者名单。名单上有 1,213 个名字。安德斯·埃克伦德排在第 21 位。琳达·舍斯特伦，那个目睹佩妮拉被勒死的十几岁女孩，提供了对肇事者“一流的”回忆。他是一个超重、头发稀疏的白人男子。这与安德斯·埃克伦德的外貌完全吻合。虽然嫌疑人名单逐渐缩减，但埃克伦德的名字一直保留着。
down, Eklund's name remained. Despite having solidified his spot on the suspect list, Andes Eklund wasn't one of the 800 men whose DNA was cross-checked against the DNA recovered from Penilla's trousers. In fact, the overwhelming majority of those men were just ordinary citizens with no history of sexual violence. Police then seemingly disregarded their suspect list altogether and instead relied heavily on tips from the public, none of which led anywhere. In November 2006, an investigative crime program detailing Penilla's murder was broadcast. 2006, an investigative crime program detailing Pernilla's murder was broadcast. An astute viewer phoned police and named Andas Eklund as someone worth looking into. Despite Eklund's
尽管他在嫌疑人名单上占据了一席之地，但安德斯·埃克伦德并不是那 800 名与从佩妮拉裤子上提取的 DNA 进行交叉比对的男性之一。事实上，这些人中的绝大多数只是没有性暴力史的普通公民。警方随后似乎完全忽视了他们的嫌疑人名单，转而严重依赖公众提供的线索，但这些线索都没有任何结果。2006 年 11 月，一个详细介绍佩妮拉谋杀案的犯罪调查节目播出。一位敏锐的观众打电话给警方，点名安德斯·埃克伦德是值得调查的人。尽管埃克伦德的
name having remained on their suspect list from its inception, investigators did nothing about this tip at all. Their reason was that nothing about it, quote, stuck out. Engla Herglund's family sued the Swedish government for the failures of police. Had they done a thorough investigation, Eklund wouldn't have been free to kill Engla after Pernilla's murder. The Stockholm District Court decided that the link between the crimes was too distant and unpredictable and therefore the lawsuit was unsuccessful. This was despite an independent inquiry into the police's conduct which found that had a competent and resourceful investigation into Penilla's murder
名字从一开始就保留在他们的嫌疑人名单上，但调查人员根本没有对这条线索采取任何行动。他们的理由是，关于它的一切引用“都不突出”。恩格拉·赫格伦的家人因警方的失职起诉了瑞典政府。如果他们进行了彻底的调查，埃克伦德就不会在佩妮拉被谋杀后还有机会杀害恩格拉。斯德哥尔摩地方法院认为，这些罪行之间的联系过于遥远且不可预测，因此诉讼未获成功。尽管一项对警方行为的独立调查发现，如果对佩妮拉的谋杀案进行了称职且资源充足的调查，
taken place, Andes Eklund would have been apprehended within months. In a 2018 interview with Publication Expressen, Engler's mother Karina described her grief at losing Engler as pain so unbearable it hurt too much to cry. Engler had an older sister named Sue, who was 11 years old when Engler was murdered. They were born just 20 months apart, affording them a relationship that was more akin to best friends than sisters. Sue told Expressen that part of her disappeared forever when Angela was killed. Despite their grief, Karina and Sule advocate for other victims of crimes. Karina has always sought to speak personally with Ander Sheklund.
安德斯·埃克伦德本会在几个月内被捕。在 2018 年接受《快报》采访时，恩格拉的母亲卡琳娜描述了她失去恩格拉的悲痛，那是一种难以忍受的痛苦，以至于痛到无法哭泣。恩格拉有一个名叫苏的姐姐，恩格拉被谋杀时她 11 岁。她们只相差 20 个月出生，这使她们的关系更像是最好的朋友而不是姐妹。苏告诉《快报》，当安吉拉被杀时，她的一部分也永远消失了。尽管悲痛万分，卡琳娜和苏还是为其他犯罪受害者进行倡导。卡琳娜一直寻求与安德斯·埃克伦德亲自交谈。
She wants the exact truth of what happened to her daughter, but he continues to deny her request for a meeting. In her interview with Expressen, Karina contemplated what Engler's life would have been like if she was still alive. Since she was a little girl, Engler loved being in the spotlight She entered as many talent contests as she could, singing and dancing to the delight of her audience A recording of Engler performing had been played during her funeral service, sharing her joy to the nation Carina imagined Engler would have grown up to live in Stockholm and attended Kulturama, the largest performing arts college in the Nordic region A statue of an angel now marks the spot in the forest where Carina found Engler's bike The name Engler in Sweden means angel. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她想要女儿遭遇的真相，但他继续拒绝她的会面请求。在接受《快报》采访时，卡琳娜思考了如果恩格拉还活着，她的生活会是什么样子。从很小的时候起，恩格拉就喜欢成为焦点。她参加了尽可能多的才艺比赛，唱歌跳舞，让观众感到愉悦。恩格拉表演的录音在她的葬礼上播放，与全国人民分享她的快乐。卡琳娜想象恩格拉长大后会住在斯德哥尔摩，并就读于北欧地区最大的表演艺术学院 Kulturama。一座天使雕像现在标记着卡琳娜发现恩格拉自行车的那片森林。在瑞典语中，恩格拉的名字意为“天使”。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。